lines of greatest challenge facing both
parties has changed its fundamental
change looking you can live in a lot of
moments in American history where the
world you're born into in the world you
govern are not that vastly different
they're always different 30 or 40 years
pass you know things are going to change
in a country but but that said you know
you can there if you were if you were
born at a certain point in the 20th
century after you know the after the
Great Depression and you were governing
in the 1960s or 1970s you know the world
was the economy was pretty much the
economy it was supposed to be it was run
by an industrial engine the world was
still divvied up among states who did
menaced each other only or you know sign
treaties and didn't manage each other in
the world is pretty much the one you had
telephones and you had television you
had nicer televisions and he had cable
TV but people were still communicating
with one another in much the same way
and they were still posting letters by
hand and sending them in a mailbox you
know and then you have a moment like
this where where the world is just
vastly different than it was 30 40 is
going in a sense we're caught between
moments right we're in between this
industrial age and what comes next
because we still have vestiges one foot
in the past vestiges of the past one
foot there one foot in the future so the
challenge for the Democratic Party or
any party is to lead the way into that
future is to articulate what what
government what and the economic engine
and foreign policy of a country are
going to look like in the era where none
of those things are operable anymore
when the economy is non-industrial
driven where people communicate with
each other all over the world in a flash
right where people expect to have
options and choices in their lives where
the threats that affect the world are
not necessarily states to States but a
bunch of people who can communicate on
the internet and do a great deal more
damage than a general in some country
can you know this is this is a whole new
landscape and what I'm coming around to
the view that it's too much to ask just
too much to ask of a generation born
into a different world to govern in this
one I think the baby boom generation has
done what it can I don't I don't I don't
indict them is you know selfish
worthless people I just think it's it
may have been just too much to ask a
generation born in the 19th
50s to figure out how to govern in the
year two thousand seven of 2008 and I
I'm not I'm coming around to the view
that leadership and real leadership and
real change and real evolution of
government will we'll have to wait for
another generation